only has one third of Earth's gravity so
your bones wouldn't experience the same
force your bones would lose their
density and become more brittle breaking
them would become a common issue on Mars
you'd be experiencing a thin atmosphere
that's mostly carbon dioxide with only
Trace Amounts of oxygen
you wouldn't be able to evolve a whole
new respiratory system but you could
develop other ways of dealing with the
lack of oxygen like you could have
denser capillaries that are more
efficient at moving blood and
transporting oxygen to your muscles
but even with these advances you'd still
have to live underground or in a thickly
insulated house to survive the harsh
atmosphere